[Music]
foreign
ER of Lucky repairs and I'm going to
teach you how to clean your Playstation
part by part
I look at repairs we specialize in
fixing anything from phones to gaming
consoles even miscellaneous things like
hair clippers and speakers sometimes I
really try to fix anything that I can
it's important to clean and maintain
your gaming console because once it
builds up this dust it blocks the
airflow inside of it causing it to
overheat once the PlayStation overheats
it either shuts down or the fan starts
spinning faster that's where you get the
jet engine sound from
this PlayStation right here is one of
the dirtiest that I've ever worked on
it's built up a lot of dust in the fan
area which prevents air from flowing
through it properly
[Music]
for this PlayStation the first step that
I am doing is removing these three
screws to pop off the bottom housing
once the bottom housing is off you can
see some of the dust that has collected
especially in the fan area
next to get deeper into the PlayStation
I take off the power supply
it could be a little finicky to take
this part off you kind of have to pop it
off of one side then wiggle it out
carefully
even then it's still connected by a wire
so before removing it completely we have
to disconnect that wire
the power supply is where you can often
find roaches because this is one of the
warmest parts of the PlayStation
watches tend to hide out inside of
PlayStations because it's dark and also
because of the heat once flipped over
the left side covers the hard drive it
actually comes right off without any
screws you just got to slide it to the
left there's one actual screw that keeps
the hard drive in place once that's
removed you just slide it right out
with the bottom removed there's a lot of
dust that built up inside of it so we'll
grab a paper towel with some all-purpose
cleaner and give it a good wipe
some PlayStation will have more dust
build up than others the dust can build
up easier especially if you have pets or
if you have it tucked away inside of a
cabinet area
before I can access the motherboard
there are a few cables and screws that
have to be taken out
then we can pop off the motherboard and
pull it away
at this point we can see more of the
dust that is built up inside the
PlayStation
I use compressed air and brushes to
clean this section off along with some
alcohol
thank you
underneath the motherboard there's even
more build up because this is where the
fan blows air through
removing this top middle piece we can
see one of the most important parts the
this is where a thick layer of dust
cakes up that you have to remove this is
the part that causes the PlayStation to
choke because the airflow is blocked
oh
[Music]
to clear this up I removed the debris
with a pair of tweezers to get the bulk
of it
then use a brush to Dust Away the rest
finally I take it outside to hit it with
some compressed air
once the heat sink is removed and clean
we have direct access to the fan this is
probably one of the most time consuming
parts of the cleaning I use a Q-tip to
dust each one of the fins individually
and with this method I have to clean
both sides of the fan
if the debris is really bad a toothbrush
can help break it up
I also use a toothbrush and compressed
air on other parts of the PlayStation
like the power supply
[Music]
once the bulk of the Dust has been blown
off outside then we can get into the
more detailed part of the cleaning
I use alcohol in a paper towel to wipe
it all down then to reach the smaller
crevices and parts I use a Q-tip and
brushes to dust it all away
[Music]
some people think it's a little
excessive to clean it this deeply but if
I'm not this thorough then you may not
even tell a difference
[Music]
another very important step to maintain
your console pool is to replace the
thermal paste thermal paste helps with
the transfer of heat from the Apu to the
heat sink thermal paste doesn't tend to
last more than four to five years once
it starts to age it gets very dry and
cracks those cracks create air pockets
between the heatsink and the chip which
causes it to overheat and you never want
that as your console could be damaged if
it gets too overheated too many times
this is a perfect example of old thermal
paste as you can see it's very dried out
and has a lot of cracks
this is one of the main reasons why a
PlayStation overheats
to clean the old thermal paste off I
used a Q-tip with a little bit of
alcohol on it to carefully remove it
this is one of the more controversial
steps of the repair is the amount of
thermal paste that one adds I add a pea
sized amount and I've never had any
issues
so once it dries out and cracks it is
very important to put a Fresh coat on
because this will cause your Playstation
to overheat
now that we are done and is put together
again we wipe the outside done and it's
ready for gaming
it's always satisfying seeing the before
and afters of these PlayStations with
the way the original PlayStation 4 is
designed cleaning it isn't as easy
because there are a lot more layers that
you have to remove to access the
heatsink they also tend to build up more
dust compared to the other consoles and
that's why I tend to see a lot more
PlayStation 4s I must drop than others
[Music]
I've been interested in electronics
since a young age just started off with
the PSP making it open like an iPhone or
even the iPods jailbreaking those
those were my middle school years and
going into some high school years that's
when I actually started messing with the
hardware replacing screens speakers and
stuff like that
some problems that people have with
their PlayStations are that it won't
turn on or the fan sounds like a jet
engine also you can have this drive
acting up or it won't accept or spit out
the disc
I love what I do because it helps people
and I get the satisfaction of fixing the
problem
thank you